nobody has ever had a roughish started
dancing with the stars than Olympic
swimmer ryan lochte no doubt about that
he was ambushed by protesters he was one
of the last to be saved this week so
what is ryan's plan to keep his head
above water so to speak oh i found out
when i was first to join him in
rehearsal the first couple to leave us
this season is Jake and Jen I was like
shaky and I was like I standing behind
her and my legs were like my hand
started sweaty and I was just like yeah
i was already just sweating from the
minor my dance i was doing it in like
then I felt your clammy hands oh my gosh
oh my gosh oh my gosh this is shaken so
when i joined ride in rehearsal this
morning he was focused on doing anything
to keep him out of the bottom two I
don't want to go through this ever again
I was like it stick what is the main
thing that you are working on with Ryan
to keep him in the game this right here
no posture posture swimmer custard yeah
this Brian's monday night cha cha will
come with an extra twist the 12
remaining contestants will be pitted
against each other to fight for immunity
Ryan will be going head-to-head in the
ballroom with IndyCar driver james
hinchcliffe who's been at the top of the
leaderboard i have not gotten a break i
haven't been able to breathe yeah both
couples will dance the same style to a
different song the couple with the
highest score will be safe from
elimination I just had to walk out and
just no no we gotta save that you're
gonna say that hopefully we can save
that till later you know